- [Narrator] Face it,
your house is filthy.
It's filled with dead skin cells, dust,
and around 200,000 different species
of bug, bacteria, and fungus.
Now, it's tempting to assume that most
of them live in your toilet.
After all it's where, you know,
but here's the thing,
the dirtiest place in your
house isn't your toilet.
It's actually you.
Household microbes lurk in
the most unlikely of places.
Take a heat loving bacteria
called Thermus aquaticus,
there guys can only be
found in two environments,
blisteringly hot geysers like
Old Faithful at Yellowstone
and your hot water heater.
Another example is Penicillium fungi.
They creep into your air
conditioner from outdoors
and when you switch on the AC
their spores get blasted around the house.
They're known to cause
allergies in 2-6% of people.
So when you notice a funny
musty smell coming from your AC
it's probably the fungus,
but before you start eyeing
your central air suspiciously,
think about this, you dump
microbes all over your body
every time you shower.
It turns out trillions of
organisms live in your shower head
pilled on top of each
other in a slimy layer
half a millimeter thick,
but that's not necessarily a problem.
Researchers found that a type
of shower dwelling microbacterium
actually boosts levels of serotonin.
That's a neurotransmitter
thought to lower stress
and increase happiness,
and when those arrant
microbacteria land on you
they join the tens of thousands
of other microbe species
that live in the dirtiest
place around, your body,
like Corynebacterium,
the microbes that give your
armpits that stinky odor
and simultaneously fight
off harmful pathogens
like E. Coli.
Meanwhile, 300 to 500 species
of microbe colonize your gut
and are thought to play a role
in maintaining your immune system,
digestive system and even mental health.
In the non bacteria category, microbes,
you've got such guests
as microscopic mites
that live on your face
and mole that colonizes into your toes.
While the idea of them
might give you chills,
microbes like these help keep you safe.
You see the number of
harmless microbial species in the world
outnumber harmful ones,
by a trillion to one.
In fact, less than 0,00000001%
of microbial species
account for nearly all
infectious diseases in the world
and all these harmless
bacteria crawling on your skin
means less room and
resources for pathogens
like antibiotic resistant microbes,
which also means they
have less opportunity
to take over and make you sick.
So even when antibiotics fail,
it could be all those
other microbes crawling in
and on you that keep you safe.
So in a way, you need to get a
little dirty to stay healthy,
but full disclosure,
that's not an excuse to
swear off your shower.
Besides, you don't wanna miss out
on that feel good microbacterium.
This video was made in large
part thanks to Rob Dunn
and the information in his
new book Never Home Alone.